opportunities and boundaries were way
larger and bigger and the world has so
much to offer
us but sometimes we are
living in a box
[Music]
maurice redder thank you so much for
being on my show how are you
i'm very good thank you for having me
thank you so much for being here where
are you calling from right now
um i'm at my home office which used to
be my daughter's room
and uh yes this is my new office which i
painted half pink i love it to make it
more happy
amazing so you have such a phenomenal
track record for from so many ceo
cfo vp positions and so many different
companies
and you know just just among them wix
that everybody here would know about
but give me a little bit of context as
to the journey that you that you've gone
through
and what really excites you about about
joining new endeavors starting new
endeavors
uh you're involved in so many things at
the same time that i just love to pick
your brain on several spots
throughout your journey and get some
insight into things that i can
push forward in my own journey later on
so narit take me back
who who are you well
okay so i am uh i'm from israel i was
born and raised in israel currently i
live in ramada sharon and
i'm married with two kids two teenagers
my career started at a very young age i
was very lucky to
join the financial advisor to the chief
of staff
as uh somebody who was only 21 years old
in charge of billions and billions of
shekels it was a great start
uh working with doug nesset and ministry
of treasury
yeah uh i'm not sure i knew how to how
much
uh how big it was you know when you are
21 you are very bold and
nothing scares you you have very little
life experience so
uh so it's a good time to start um
when i i was a finance officer and when
i finished my uh
service in the army i started my career
and then um
i just i fulfilled many positions in
finance and operations i was still full
of
several exciting high-tech companies uh
i was in charge of operations and hr
um i can tell you by the way
uh that one of the smart
uh things that uh i can tell i
i made many mistakes but uh uh
one good thing that i did is took every
opportunity that was
you know that came through i just jumped
in and this is
a major uh factor in the in the
in my career because uh i had the
opportunity not to deal
only with finance uh i could
take operational responsibility and idea
opportunity and so i found myself uh
fulfilling not only cfo positions but
also
in charge of hr and sometimes i.t and it
really
you know enriched my career and
um then uh in 2013 i had this
amazing opportunity again again a huge
door was opened
two weeks um and i must say again that
uh
i i got to know wix in 2008
um my amazing neighbor omel shai
uh told me about this amazing company
that is called wix
and uh i don't know if many people heard
of it
uh back then i don't know wow
yes but then you know i i went to a
meeting there nothing uh
you know came to something real but a
few years later
i met again with abhishai and neil
the one and only and nia navishai and
the two and only maybe
um so and then they offered me to be
this
was in this position of vp of operations
which i
didn't really know what it meant um
i'm not sure they knew but i just felt
it
in my gut that i would never say no to
it and i
jumped right in and these were
you know amazing five years in which i
did
anything but the things that i did
before
uh i was managing uh i was reading
customer solutions group i was managing
wix's assets
um i had the opportunity to establish
the
establish the wix hub what is the web
sub
the wix hub was the first time that we
realized
uh that you know wix is an online
product right
uh but online and offline must be
or on life and online must be connected
uh there is no other way and our
customers were the small medium
businesses and we wanted to hear them
so the hub connected between those
small medium businesses uh owners
and our product uh on one way we
one hand we could hear what they need
and how they use our product and on the
other hand we could
help them uh use the product better with
training with seminars
it was like you know a place full of
activity it started in israel
continued in the u.s and you know along
the way we also established the
accelerator for uh women entrepreneurs
so
entrepreneurship was the name of the
game uh in
weeks yes i myself by the way during
that time i established my non-profit
called the lead
uh it's a personal story i wanted to
raise
awareness uh for excessive blood
clotting
and uh i now have a community of 4 000
members and
we want a knesset award but trust me
it's a
long way to go still but i can tell you
that weeks affected me
doing that uh it's again that thing of
the community
this element of the community how you
create a community how you deliver the
message
how do you create a shared purpose
so uh this is by the way a whole new
area that we can i can talk about for
hours because well
i wanna also go back for a second
because i'm seeing a pattern here of
jumping onto opportunities
you're talking about finding yourself a
21 being the aid to the chief of staff
with regards to financials and then
going on to
various cfo positions and landing at the
end of vp operations at wix even though
you have no idea what vp operations does
so talking a little bit about this
mindset this growth mindset of
harnessing opportunities and moving
forward with them
well okay so i can talk about a few
things
one uh i was always a dreamer
i thought i was a dreamer i i thought i
aimed
high and so i didn't limit myself only
to being
you know the age of 21 my dream was to
be a cfo of a company
but then uh i kind of
uh reached it quite early and then i
i didn't know where to aim next and it
was quite
uh confusing uh i read i very much
believe in
aiming high but uh when i came to weeks
i understood
i was not aiming high at all i mean
opportunities and boundaries were
way larger and bigger and the
world has so much to offer us
but sometimes we are living in a box
and uh i found out that i cannot live in
a box
i mean from some uh from time to time i
returned to my box
but it never lasts so my box is is
finance
uh but my gut uh was stronger
than the box thing and i can tell you
that every time
a door opened whether it was uh being a
cfo of a product division at the age of
where uh it was selling for 100 million
dollars i
jumped into it when my boss was sick and
somebody had to take
some project going to the u.s presenting
it
project i also jumped into it i just
didn't say no
uh to new opportunities when it scared
me
i went for it uh and this was one
good thing that i did uh but uh
i think that you should always dream
uh like there is this book that i read
uh the ten times rule or something like
that you need to dream
really like uh big and scary dreams
because then you know you are doing the
you know you're aiming to the right
direction um
wow i think that's very very cool
yes i think that uh i always put i mean
my career was always important for me i
i
i put it first maybe it's not that
popular to say it when you are a mother
or politically correct but i can tell
you that i don't know
any other way to succeed in something
that you are aiming to
to excel at uh if you want to succeed in
something you cannot just tell yourself
okay it's a saturday i'm forgetting
about work it's merging
into your life and i have very i mean
i have many examples of why it's
important and why when you are focused
you can succeed so this is another thing
that
i can tell you give me a little bit of
insight into the mistakes you've made
you've mentioned that you've made you've
made a lot of mistakes along the way
but you've grew from you've grown from
there and you you've learned from them
so
what are some you know mistakes that
that you
signal out along the way that are clear
to you that they've helped you in your
trajectory
whether it's through learning or empathy
or just
understanding yeah well
that's a very good question and i've
been thinking about it a lot so one
thing is that i didn't
aim high enough i can tell you that i
have that
entrepreneurship in me for
forever and only now
i reached the point where i'm doing my
own thing my own business
something that i'm super super
passionate about that i'm willing to
uh invest immensely at and you know
without any boundaries well i have that
uh
privilege that my kids are older now so
i have more time but i can tell you
that it wasn't the case in the last 20
uh
years of her career it was not always uh
and when at weeks for example i had
opportunities that i was
amazed to be given i just gave
everything
and i didn't always i wasn't always
lucky to have those opportunities but
you need to create your own
opportunities
that was something that i should have
and you need to be
fearless and that was uh scared
of many things going uh to do my own
thing
was something that was inconceivable you
know
to me and now at a
later age i now i dare
and so this is one thing i can tell you
there are so many
uh well so about this daring and and
trying new things
you approach these opportunities and how
do you
navigate your environment so there's
expectation of you from others
there's a expectation of you from
yourself and then there's what your
actual skill sets are at that moment and
you know that there's going to be a big
learning curve and a big
you know a big journey to get there
so how do you is it it sounds like a
pretty lonely journey
to sometimes be in that phase where it's
it
they are expecting something and now you
have to own up to it and now you have to
do this
internal journey to reach that milestone
right
yes wow that's a that's an amazing
question
um so this goes back to
doing right or wrong uh in
you know in making decisions so i think
my conclusion
is that the only way you can succeed
while you
would like to grow is by partnering with
a colleague with a few colleagues
creating a coalition having a partner
when i did that
and i not always used that
way but when i did it it just flew
it just you know i had a partner i would
not say his name
he was from a different discipline which
is also important because i come from
finance operation hr i can do that
but i cannot do r d for example and if i
want to do something big if i wanted to
do something big something
as strategic something with impact
so that was the only way because
uh you can't do it otherwise
uh certainly in a large organization but
also in a startup
uh if you wanna do a
an important move something that will
really affect the life of the company
and make you feel like you gave your
best
you need to partner you need to complete
your skills with other people's skills
you cannot do it alone you simply cannot
so
that's the way what has been most
exciting for you on your journey
like are there certain points in time
when you really feel like you are your
true
self and you're really fulfilling your
destiny
wow uh i'm not sure i know what my
is yet uh i always i'm always hoping
that
what i do currently is the most you know
exciting things
and i feel like it right now because uh
we are in the beginning of this journey
of creating our
own startup in uh in something that i
very much believe in
um something that uh i learned a lot
uh being at wix everything that i
mentioned
about community when i i will tell you
this when i was at
wix i was part of an employee community
uh
which i was very proud to be part of and
i asked myself what why why wasn't
what why was i so proud um
and the elements are coming from
different kinds of
worlds one is for example that
you had your responsibility on your
shoulders
you could do many initiatives you can
lead
things that never existed before in that
organization but it was on your shoulder
everything was measured
you can picture that with me when you
enter every
floor at weeks you can see graphs
and numbers and for me as a finance
person it was
a shock because everything was
transparent
but uh the amazing thing which i
realized
few months after was that it was
aligning everybody
everybody knew company goals everybody
wanted the company to succeed and they
knew
what it meant to to be successful
and on top of everything that i'm
talking about right now which is like
the business world everything was
wrapped in this uh
gift wrap of uh taking care of employees
having many many many
events you are always being uh
seen you can you know you are on the
stage
somebody is taking care of you you know
uh that
your voice is heard so the social
element is very strong and very much
connected to the business
world so what i'm doing right now in my
startup
is trying to take uh this
to the online world because this is
where we are going to be i mean
as i said in the beginning online and on
life will always be connected
we are not going to run away from that
but how do you create an online
organizational culture uh you know in a
platform
how do you create all of these amazing
elements
in a platform online so this is
something that
i'm very excited about uh
very passionate about i hope it's uh
going to fulfill my destiny but
again i don't know what my destiny is
it's a big thing i need to think about
it
what are the most critical parts for you
as you as you think about who you want
to work with and the people you want to
align yourself with whether it's for
this startup or for any other project
uh well again people
make everything uh this is something
that uh
i learned along the way uh sometimes
you're taking people with not exactly
the skills
that you need but you know they are
smart you know they are they have a
heart
uh and they know how to work together
and in bad times this is the test right
so
there is no uh you know you never work
on a project and it's all roses and
smelling like
hearts little hearts i don't know uh you
have those
obstacles that you need to deal with and
you need that person to be next to you
and i had
i had the luck to have a few people
like this along you know near me in uh
in those situations but situations and
we are still you know 10 years past 15
years past
but uh it's not always the case so it's
again it's an intuition or
friends and now i am uh i've partnered
to a real friend
so this is why i'm so happy
great thank you so much for being
generous with your time this is the this
is really really great i really
appreciate it and
at the very last question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
three words okay uh that's a challenge
so i'm
a family woman uh
i don't know if there is such an
expression i am
a career woman um
and i am an entrepreneur
i love it narita thank you very much to
dogba this is really great
and i look forward to trying this with
the world thank you
thank you so much